Hi, everyone.
So first of all,
great to see you here.
My name is Daniele Gammelli.
I'm a postdoc in the
Autonomous Systems
Lab in the Department of
Aeronautics and Astronautics.
As you might guess from the
accent, I'm also Italian.
So if optimal control
doesn't work for you,
I guess you'll be experts in
Italian accents at the very
least.
So for today, the plan is
that-- so over the last week,
we started introducing
the general formalism
for optimal control.
Specifically, we introduced the
general problem formulation,
which is something along
the lines of-- we're
given a dynamical
system x of t, which
is in the form of a
differential equation.
And the overall goal for us was
to determine an optimal control
signal, u star of t, that
minimizes some objective, which
we defined as having a
terminal cost h of x of tf
for the final time tf
plus our running cost.
And then so this we
realized that this
was in an infinite dimensional.
Yes?
Can you use a different board?
All right.
Again, nothing new here.
What I was saying here is we
defined the optimal control
problem as a dynamical system,
where we wanted to define
an optimal control u star of t.
And this control then steers the
state trajectory x of t in a way
that we can optimize
an objective function
j, which is composed of two
terms, a terminal state--
terminal cost h of x of tf
evaluated at the final time
plus a running cost.
Again, I don't want to just--
don't take too much out of this
exactly, because we
saw this already.
And then given that
we realized that this
is an infinite dimensional
optimization problem,
we then went into--
opened a parenthesis
about finite dimensional
optimization,
where we started
by defining, first
of all, what we mean by
minima or maxima, that are
the objects of interest for us.
And then we went into defining
necessary optimality conditions
for the unconstrained
case first,
namely the fact that
gradient of f of x
needs to be equal to 0,
so be a stationary point
of our objective function f.
And then we did the same for
the constrained case, namely
the equality constraint case.
And so for today,
we'll just quickly
wrap up last week's
lecture, where
we will be defining the
necessary optimality conditions
for the inequality
constrained case.
And then s move to the
content of today's topic,
which are then essentially our
first step into optimal control,
where we'll be trying to
have a similar approach that
is defining necessary
optimality conditions,
this time for the infinite
dimensional optimal control
problem.
Any questions on the plan
and does this make sense?
All right.
OK.
So first of all, when we
say inequality constraints,
we essentially refer to
an optimization problem
of this form.
So we're minimizing,
as usual, our objective
function f of x subject to some
equality constraints, which
is exactly the setting
we were seeing last week.
So h of i of x needs to be equal
to 0 for m equality constraints.
And then here, we're introducing
our inequality constraints
represented as gj of x.
It needs to be less
than or equal than 0.
And we're assuming here that
f, h, and all the gj's are
continuously differentiable.
Again, this problem can be
written in compact form, which
we will be referring to as
the ICP, so the inequality
constraint problem, where we
are essentially compacting
this in vector notation.
So all the letters become
basically boldface.
But this is the
kind of problem we
are looking at when we say
inequality constraint optimal
control problem.
And so when we introduce
inequality constraints, kind
of mathematically, this object
becomes much more difficult.
And we could spend
a series of lectures
into defining the optimality
constraints for this case.
However, what I will do
today is essentially,
I will try to take an
easy route in defining
the optimality constraints.
And what I mean by
easy route is that we
will try to reuse as
much as possible what
we derived last week with
the equality constraints.
And the way we do this is
through something which we
refer to as active constraint.
So specifically for
any feasible point,
the set of active
inequality constraints
is denoted as this A of
x, which is essentially
the set of all the
inequality constraints,
gj's, that are respected
at the equality.
On the other hand, all
the other constraints
that are not respected at
the equality, so are strictly
less than 0, we will be
defining them as inactive at x.
So more visually,
say that we have
a problem along the
lines of minimizing
x plus y, subject to the fact
that x and y must be greater
than 0, and x plus y
needs to be less than 3.
What we're looking
at is something
where-- first of
all, it has to be
in the positive
side of the plane.
And then we have
this constraint here,
which essentially defines
the feasible region
to be this one over here.
Can you guys see from
the back over there?
Yeah.
So in this case,
the minimum-- so
if you look at the level curves
of our objective functions,
there are something
that look like this.
And so in this case, the minimum
point would be at the origin.
So if we take this
point, so 0, 0,
at this point out of
the three constraints,
we have that these two are
respected at the equality.
So these two will be active.
On the other hand, this
constraint over here
is not respected
at the equality.
So this is inactive.
OK.
And so given that this
definition is clear,
this point is where
most of, I would say,
the brainpower for understanding
this easy route goes into.
Specifically what we're saying
here is that if x of star
is a local minimum
of the ICP, which
is the full problem that we
saw on the previous slides,
so this one here, what we're
saying is that then x of star
is also a local minimum
for the identical ICP
without the inactive
constraints.
And to give you an intuition,
the proof for this argument
usually goes by contradiction.
So we're saying
that x of star is
a local minimum of
the original ICP,
so with all
constraints included.
But let us assume
that this is not
a local minimum for
the problem without
the inactive constraints.
So if it is not a local
minimum, what this would mean
is that we would be able to
move in the neighborhood of that
x of star while
respecting the constraints
and still finding a better
value of the objective function.
At the same time, so if we are
moving into a neighborhood,
we can find a neighborhood
that is arbitrarily
small, such that the
inactive constraints always
remain inactive.
And if you're following me
until here, what we're saying
is that if this is true,
then all the constraints
of the original problem
would still be satisfied.
And so this would mean that we
would have found a better point
also for the original problem.
Therefore, kind of concluding
the contradiction here.
Right.
So if you will--
again, don't take
me by the exact word
here, but what we are
saying is that we can always
think of a neighborhood
of this point x star.
So if this is not a
minimum of this problem,
we can define a neighborhood
that is arbitrarily small, such
that we can move along this
minimum and find a new point
x prime, such that the value
of the function at x prime
is smaller than the
original f of x prime.
And specifically, since I
can take this neighborhood
to be arbitrarily small, I
could move in the direction
that it satisfies all of
my original constraints,
so the equality constraints, but
also the ones that are inactive,
because the inactive
ones always have-- you
could think about it intuitively
as there is some margin
that I can play with.
And so if this is
true, then I would
have found a point that is
better for the original problem
as well.
And so this is not the case.
Does this make sense?
OK.
And so what we're seeing here
is that at the local minimum,
active inequality
constraints can essentially
be treated to a large
extent as equalities.
And so you're probably
starting to guess a little bit
where we're going now.
So remember, what
we're trying to do here
is define the optimality
conditions for inequality
constraint problems.
And we said, we want to take
the, quote unquote, "easy route"
of leveraging as much as
possible the results that we got
in the equality constraint case.
And so here what
we just proved is
that if x is a local
minimum of the full problem,
that is the full inequality
constraint problem,
then it is also local minimum
for the version of the problem
where I'm only considering
the active constraints.
Yes?
When you're saying that it's
a local of the constraint,
are you assuming that
you're not on the boundary?
Even with that example, if
you cross the boundary out
of the constraints, you
could be going lower
or it would not be local.
Yeah, exactly.
So this is what I meant by
don't take it too rigorously
here, because here, there
is actually only this one
point that we're considering.
But maybe you could
imagine something
like in three
dimensions, maybe, where
I have my inequality constraints
being some kind of hyperplanes,
and satisfying both means lying
on this subspace over here.
Then you could think that moving
in a neighborhood of this point,
I could still respect my
original equality constraints.
Does this [INAUDIBLE]?
As long as you are
not on the boundary,
essentially, is what that
previous point was saying,
then that is true.
Because we are on the boundary.
You can cross the boundary and
become a lower [INAUDIBLE].
No, of course, we want to
respect all the constraints.
Yes.
The previous point,
only-- you're
saying only is of concern if
you are not on the boundary.
By previous point, you
mean that also the--
The local minimum of that
is also the local minimum
without the constraints.
That's only true if the
local minimum is only
within the boundary and not--
If the local minimum
is a feasible point.
Yes.
So it's a local--
it's within the bounds
and not on the boundary.
If it's on--
Well, in this case, it
is a boundary, right?
Yeah.
But if crossing the boundary
outside of the constraints
means you have a
lower point, then--
so the local minimum without
the active rates is a different
local minimum than with the
constraints, because you're--
one is in the boundary.
one is not in the boundary.
Yes.
Well, if you're going across the
boundary in the feasible region,
then yes.
That means you don't
care about that.
Yeah.
So then that is only true
then when you're within--
you're not on the
boundary, right, 0.1?
I mean, again, the fact is
that boundary here it depends,
because we--
boundary-- I guess,
you're saying when
these constraints are active.
So some of them will be at
the boundaries and some won't.
Yeah.
So I guess I'm
confused where you
say it's a local minimum
without the constraints,
just because you have a local
minimum within the constraints.
But if you're in the boundary,
that's not necessarily true.
Because when you talk
about the previous thing,
it's like on the boundary,
you might have a more minimum,
you have a lower
value, but because you
can't cross the boundary, you
have to keep the local boundary.
Yeah.
So it's only a local minimum
outside of the constraints
if you are within
the boundary itself.
Yes, I think that's about-- yes.
Does the general picture
make sense apart from this?
Yeah.
Any other questions on this?
OK.
So basically what
we're saying here
is that x is a local
minimum of the original ICP,
then it is also a local
minimum for the same problem
where we remove the inactive
inequality constraints
and only keep the active ones.
And if we think about
what we did last week,
this is an object we can
basically work with and derive
optimality conditions.
So remember that last time we
were defining the Lagrangian
as L of x lambda, we're
introducing some Lagrangian
multipliers lambda, equals f
of x plus the summation from i
to m, which is where m
is the number of equality
constraints of lambda i times,
I think we call them h, so hi
of x.
And then we use this to derive
necessary optimality conditions,
such that the gradient
of the Lagrangian
needs to be equal to 0.
Can you use a darker marker?
I think this was
the darker marker.
So again, this is
from last lecture.
So what we're just
saying is that we
use this to define necessary
optimality conditions.
So we define the Lagrangian.
And then we just said
that the gradient
with respect to this Lagrangian
function needs to be equal to 0.
So these were the
optimality conditions
in the equality
constraint case, which
boil down to a
system of n plus n
equations in n plus m unknowns.
And so what I'm saying here
is that this is exactly
the same case now
that we did this step.
And so we can apply the
exact same reasoning
in defining the optimality
conditions for the ICP
with the inactive constraints
removed, where again, this
is exactly the same necessary
optimality conditions we derived
for the equality constraint case
with the addition of this term
over here, which takes care of
only the active constraints,
that is the inequality
constraints that are respected
at the boundary, where again,
we have this Lagrangian term mu
j star times the gradient of
the inequality constraints.
And everything has
to be equal to 0.
Or equivalently, we can
write the exact same thing.
So here nothing new, just
rewriting a little bit more
elegantly where rather than
having a summation over only
the active
constraints, I can have
a summation over all inequality
constraints, so from r1 to r,
with the additional
condition that the mu's
need to be equal to 0 for
all the inactive constraints.
There is an
additional condition,
that is the
multipliers mu j that
relate with the inequality
constraints have to be positive.
There are some kind of
geometric interpretations
and proofs we could
do here, but it's
beyond the scope
of this lecture.
Yes?
For the concept
of the [INAUDIBLE]
for equality constraints also,
there could be [INAUDIBLE].
Well, I mean, the equality--
either you are at the equality
or you're not respecting it.
So it's slightly
different, I think.
Does it make sense?
If we solve this for the
global minimum with respect
to the active
constraints, are we
guaranteed to also be
satisfying the inactive ones,
or is it something we
have to iterate on?
No, this is exactly
the point I was
trying to make earlier that
we-- again, we kind of did
a sketch of a proof.
But what we proved
here is that if x
is a local minimum of
the original problem,
then it is also local minimum
of the problem removed
the inactive constraints.
[INAUDIBLE]
Yes.
So here the entire
goal is just to come up
with optimality conditions.
Yeah.
So there's more terms here.
Can you knock a gh
of 2, for example?
What does any of
that-- any example?
The example, you
mean this one here?
Yeah.
So in this case,
there are no h's.
So this is f, our
objective function.
There are no h's because h for
us is the equality constraint.
So here, we are assuming we only
have inequality constraints.
And all of these would be g's.
So this would be g1, this would
be g2, and this would be g3.
Of course, here, I'm not
respecting the formalism that
I'm--
whereby we only use less
than or equal than 0,
but you could just flip
the sign here and get that.
Does this make sense?
And then what about A?
So A is the set of
active constraints,
A of x is a set of active
constraint at a point x.
So it depends on the point.
We were assuming we have
this point here as our x.
In this case, A of 0, 0,
which is this x over here,
would be these two
constraints, so 1 and 2,
because this is inactive.
Yeah?
Can I [INAUDIBLE]
point for the region
for which the
[? sign ?] is active?
What's the method for that?
So here for us,
we just defining A
of x as the set of
active constraints.
So we are not talking
about regions necessarily.
We're just referring-- it's
literally a set of indices.
So in this case,
it would be 1 and 2
referring to constraint number
1 and constraint number 2.
This is the one that
you just-- point
that we'll talked
about the constraints
and see what [INAUDIBLE]
for any [INAUDIBLE].
Sorry, can repeat this?
So if you find that constraints,
just plug-in the values of point
and see where it's going?
For the example, correct.
Yes?
So then I guess I
just [INAUDIBLE].
So how would you then identify--
for example, you have 0, 0, 1.
It's 1 and 2 that are active.
3 isn't.
Is it like then is
active if you're
like right on the
boundaries that's
why the third constraint
is not active?
If you say moved it to
3 and 0, would it then
be that 2 and 3 would be active?
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, so active is when you
substitute the value of x and y
here and you get
an equality out.
OK.
Yes?
Is there such a thing for
the inequality contraints?
Because if it's constrained
to be on two lines
and you're not on
there, then that just
means that neither of those
are satisfied as well.
Or is it just for
inequality constraints?
I don't think I got that.
Is there a similar thing--
unless I'm missing the point
of the active constraint thing.
It's just the area that
satisfied by all of them.
So would there--
like everything--
You're talking about
the physical set?
Yeah.
For equality, is there
a version of that?
I mean, if the theta we have--
indeed this problem here.
So you imagine we have
two equality constraints,
such that in--
of course, in three dimensions.
So one equality constraint is
we have to lie on this plane.
Another equality constraint,
you have to lie on this plane.
Then the feasible region
is this part over here.
OK.
All right.
So all of this to boils down
towards the necessary optimality
conditions for the inequality
constraint problems, which
are known as Karush-Kuhn-Tucker
conditions or KKT, which
essentially goes as follows.
So we, once again,
define the Lagrangian
function L of x lambda
mu, where lambda mu are
Lagrangian multipliers.
We used this object
then to define
the optimality conditions.
And so the theorem of basically
the KKT condition states that
if x of star is a local
minimum for the full inequality
constraint problem, where f,
h, and g's are all continuously
differentiable, and we assume
that x of star is [INAUDIBLE],
again, kind of--
you can ignore this for now.
But in general, we're
saying that the equality
and active inequality
constraints
are-- the gradients are
linearly independent.
Then it means that there exists
a unique Lagrange multiplier
vectors, so the lambdas
and the mu's, such
that the gradient of the
Lagrangian is equal to 0.
The mu j's in correspondence
to the inactive constraints
are equal to 0.
And in general, they're all
positive, so non-negative.
Again, so here, we're
just putting together
the results we arrived at.
OK.
So now to ground the
intuition a little bit--
yes?
In this case, we are presently
only checking the boundaries,
because we're only checking
whether it is equal.
And so if we find one on the
boundary, then we're like,
oh, we found it.
We never checked within
the boundaries, right?
So this is a
necessary condition.
Meaning if a point
is a local minimum,
it has to satisfy this
condition over here.
So it does not mean that all--
so what it means is
that all local minimums
satisfy this condition.
Yeah.
So for example,
x sub 1, 1, which
is none of those
constraints you have there,
in terms of the
equality constraints.
Because it's not x equals 0.
It's not y equals 0.
And it's not y plus x equals 3.
It would never show
up in your set.
The a, 1, 1 would be
nothing of the set.
So you would never
have it on there,
but it could be a
minimum in this problem.
X sub 1, 1 could be a minimum?
Yeah, it could be because it
satisfies all the constraints.
And let's say the gradient and--
[INAUDIBLE] the
gradient is, right?
But it's never being checked
in your problem, because a of 1
is nothing with that,
because it's not equal to 0.
X is not equal to 0.
Y is not equal to 0.
And x plus y is not equal to 3.
I'm afraid I'm not exactly
following your argument,
but I would have
to take that on you
because we have a
full lecture to cover.
I'm happy to stay afterwards
if you want offline.
Yes?
Isn't it necessary
condition that at least one
of the inequality
constraints is active?
The necessary condition on what?
To solve the point.
To have it be a solution
for the problems.
There are at least-- one of
the constraints is inner.
So it's a property of problems
that usually solutions
are at tension points
between objective function
and constraints.
And so usually, yes.
All right.
So to make a small example of
what it means to apply this,
hopefully to ground
the intuition,
so let us solve
this problem over
here where we want
to minimize x squared
plus epsilon squared subject
to one inequality constraints.
That is 2x plus y less
than or equal than 2.
Can you see with this marker?
Is it good enough?
Yes.
Yeah.
All right.
And let's be methodical, right?
So let's apply the
KKT conditions.
So first of all, what we need is
we need to compute the gradient
of f, which in this case
is simply 2x and 2y, right?
And the gradient of our
inequality constraints,
so grad of g, which
is 2 and 1, right?
So we're using this
to characterize
the gradient of our Lagrangian.
And the inequality constraints
are slightly trickier
in the sense that you
need to consider cases,
in the case of the constraints
are active or inactive.
And so let's look at
the first case, case 1,
where we are assuming that
the constraint is active.
That is that 2x plus
y is equal to 2.
Now, we indeed write that the
gradient of the Lagrangian is
equal to 0 condition, which
essentially means that 2xy plus
mu times our gradient of our
constraints is equal to 0.
So this is our gradient of the
Lagrangian has to be equal to 0.
And of course, we also have that
the mu's need to be positive.
Mu needs to be positive.
Well, non-negative.
From this, we can write
that 2x plus 2 mu equals 0,
2y plus mu equals 0, which
essentially means that x is
equal to negative mu and y is
equal to negative mu over 2.
OK.
All right.
Now, if we plug these into
our active constraint,
so we have values for
x and y, what we get
is 2 mu equal to 2,
which essentially
means that mu is
equal to negative 4
over 5, which is not
possible because we
want to choose to be positive.
Well, non-negative.
So this is not
what we need here.
All right.
And so we try with a
second case, case 2,
which is where we assume that
the constraint is now inactive,
meaning 2x plus y is
strictly less than 2.
Now, in this case, we know that
for all inactive constraints,
the mu's are equal to 0.
And so our gradient of the
Lagrangian essentially becomes
2x to y plus 0, because this is
mu times the gradient of x of g,
which essentially means
that x and y are equal to 0.
Now, this satisfies
the constraint
because if we plug these values
here, it is indeed less than 2.
And so this is indeed a
candidate for a local optimum.
And to convince you that--
I mean, this was not
like a hard problem,
because-- just to
convince you that what
we did makes sense, what
we are characterizing here
is a problem where we
wanted to basically satisfy
this inequality
constraint, which
defines this line over here.
And so the feasible region
is in this part of the line.
And our objective
function is like a ball
that originates in 0 0.
And so indeed, the
local minimum here--
well, global minimum
in this case is 0 0.
Yes?
I apologize if I
missed it before.
Could you explain why
we use 0 in case 2?
So here, we defined that--
if you remember how we
derived the KKT conditions,
is that we essentially
define the problem
to be identical to the equality.
And so we derived this
condition over here,
which could be
equivalently rewritten such
that we were
iterating or summing
over all inequality conditions,
inequality constraints,
with the additional
condition that the mu has
to be 0 for all the
inactive constraints.
And so in this case,
we were in a case
where we were assuming this
constraint is inactive.
And so for this constraint,
the mu has to be 0.
So when the constraint
is inactive here,
the mu is equal to 0.
Yes, correct.
Again, here, what
we're saying is that--
this is an example
of how we could use
these optimality conditions.
So we did all of
this work to say--
to come up with a condition
that we can use to potentially
filter for candidates.
So we use this.
We find potential
candidates for optimality.
And then we check if
it makes sense or not.
Yes?
Why should mu be non-negative
for the [? active ?]
constraints?
Yes, this is the point I was--
I'm happy to share with
you some literature.
It gets a little bit tricky.
There are some geometrical
interpretations,
but they're beyond the
scope of this class.
Yes?
Is there a multiple [INAUDIBLE]?
Exactly.
This is where it
gets tricky in here.
We use only one constraint.
Yeah.
So in case 1, it would have to
be greater than or equal to 0.
[INAUDIBLE] positive,
strictly positive.
In case 1, mu would have
to be strictly positive.
Well, no, right?
Because here, what we're
saying is that the-- so these
are the conditions.
So we're just applying
the conditions nominally.
And basically, the conditions
entail that for all constraints,
the mu has to be non-negative,
except for the ones that
are inactive, where they
actually have to be 0.
Yes?
So am I understanding
it correctly
that the conclusion that we
drew from check in case 1
is that there just does not
exist a candidate for optimality
that has this active concern?
Yeah, correct.
Again, here is
one simple example
of how you could use optimality
conditions just as a way
to filter out candidates.
Yeah.
OK.
And so this actually wraps
the content for lecture 2.
So let me just grab--
OK.
Any other questions on
this before we move on?
Perfect.
And so with this,
now, we essentially
laid the foundation
of some intuitions
that relate with finite
dimensional optimization.
And now, we are--
and this is important
because we will be coming
back to these ideas
over and over in this
class, at the very least
for the optimal part
of this class before we
go into learning.
And now, we start essentially
exploring our roadmap.
And this is a slide
we will be coming
to over and over because
it just helps you,
I think, in grounding what
we're covering exactly.
And so specifically for the
next two to three weeks,
we will be focused on this
quadrant of our roadmap.
That is open loop methods
for optimal control, which
are to be differentiated from
closed loop methods, which
entail finding a closed
loop policy for behavior.
And specifically for the next
three lectures within the class
of open loop methods, we'll be
looking at indirect methods,
which is historically how
optimal control started back
in the '60s and '70s, which--
and so we will look at indirect
methods and then move towards
direct methods, which,
on the other hand, are
the more modern and way--
modern way to solve optimal
control problems in practice.
So what are indirect methods?
So at the high level,
indirect methods
are essentially a mechanism
for which we basically
go and define and determine
necessary optimality
conditions for optimal control
problems and solve for those.
So if you wish,
everything that we
have been doing so far in
the finite dimensional case.
So we have defined these optimal
control problems depending on
if they're constrained or not.
We derived optimality
conditions and used as we just
did, for example, these
optimality conditions to filter
out candidates for
optimal, for minimums.
In the exact same
way, indirect methods
try to use the exact
same formalism.
That is, define
optimality conditions
and use those to
filter out solutions,
this time for the
original problem,
which is the one we were looking
at the beginning, which is
the one in infinite dimensions.
So we are looking at the
dynamical system, which
is with the objective function
that we were describing before.
And what I mean by the
fact that this is actually
an infinite dimensional
optimization
problem is because while
here kind of variables
are essentially
vectors, in this case,
we are interested in optimizing
kind of a full signal u of t
in between time t0 and tf.
So you should imagine
that for us, u of t
is the full signal that we want
to optimize, not a single point.
OK.
And indirect methods
are also known
as optimized then discretized.
And this is because
optimize refers
to deriving optimality
conditions, which
kind of as a
spoiler, in the case
of infinite
dimensional problems,
these optimality conditions,
as we will see today,
will essentially end up
being differential equations.
And then discretized because
these differential equations,
in order to solve them,
we typically feed them
through solvers,
numerical solvers, which
entail some discretization.
And these are to
be kind of compared
to direct methods,
which, on the other hand,
are usually referred to as
discretized then optimize.
So we are given
an optimal control
problem in continuous time.
We discretize time
by, for example,
using a specific
discretization of time,
replacing integrals with
sums-- with summations
and so forth, and
then optimizing
this finite-- this
discrete time problem.
And so you can see how these
two methods are in a way
nicely complementary.
But so why do we
bother kind of going
through these ancient tools,
such as indirect methods?
And the point is that sometimes
indirect methods provide
a more direct,
that is analytical
or semi-analytical solution
for the optimal control
problem, which is great because
it means that at deployment
on board, we have to do very
little computation, which
is great in the case
where we have only
limited compute environments.
For example, in aerospace,
these are highly, highly used.
And at the same time,
indirect methods
are also typically used to
maybe provide initial guesses
for direct methods.
And so the message here is
that I'm not wasting your time.
So these techniques
are usually--
can be quite
mathematically challenging.
And this is because, kind of
as a result of this, books
and textbooks and
material is generally
written by mathematicians,
which is great.
They're perfect, but
also sometimes they
do not really follow the
desiderata of control engineers.
And so I definitely
advise you to go
through this
reference over here,
which I think strikes
a nice middle ground.
OK.
So in general, so we were
referring to this problem
before, but so now, we
are taking the first step
into tackling the
optimal control problem
kind of at first hand.
And again, what we're
saying is that we
want to find an admissible
control u star, which
causes the dynamical system
defined by a differential
equation to follow an admissible
trajectory x of stars that
minimizes the functional j.
And what we saw last week,
and at the beginning today,
is that for a function,
we essentially
defined optimality
conditions that boil down
to setting the gradient to
0 to find stationary points,
and then either using higher
order derivatives to determine
whether these are
maximums or minimums,
or just iterate through
all of the candidates
and check if these
are feasible, and what
is the minimum among
these candidates.
We'll do something very
similar for function out, which
is the extension of a function
in infinite dimensions.
So loosely speaking,
functionals can be thought
of as functions over functions.
And again, very mechanically
what we mean by this
is that u of t, in this
case, is an entire signal,
an entire function, as
we were saying before,
and j, which in this
case is a functional,
is something that takes
as input a full function
and spits out, in this
case, a scalar number, which
is a measure of optimality.
And the tool I'll be using today
to introduce these and derive
these optimality
conditions is referred
to as calculus of
variations, which
is a generalization
of calculus that
allows to find maxima and
minima of functionals,
specifically by
using variations.
And we'll see more
in the next slides
what we mean by variations.
Calculus of variations
is even more ancient
than indirect methods.
It dates back 300, 400 years.
And it's really kind
of a fundamental kind
of subfield of calculus.
And once again,
these topics can be
extremely heavy from a
mathematical standpoint.
And so in order to
be focused on what
is the goal for us in this
class, what I'll try to do here
is that I'll essentially
be constantly mapping
between the results
that we want to obtain
in the infinite
dimensional case,
that is, through calculus of
variation, to the intuitions
that we built in the
finite dimensional case,
in order that is probably
the setting we are all
most familiar with.
And specifically,
we will start by--
so if you look at
this agenda, this
is essentially the
one-to-one mapping
on what we did on
last week Monday.
So we'll start by introducing
concepts for functionals.
For example, defining
what is a functional,
what it means for two functions
to be close to each other, what
it means to be a minimum or an
extreme point for functionals.
And then we'll
use this to derive
what is referred to as the
fundamental theorem of calculus
of variations.
That is the necessary
and optimality conditions
for the infinite
dimensional problem.
And then we will apply
this to optimal control.
Any questions on the plan or
questions so far in general?
OK.
All right.
So what I'll be doing
for the next 15 minutes
is probably a bit boring, but
it introduces the terminology
and notation that we
need going forward.
And so specifically,
a functional j
is a rule of correspondence
that assigns to each function
x in a certain class
omega, say the class
of continuous functions,
a unique real number.
And it is always useful to
look through an example.
So for example, a
possible functional
is this functional
j of x, which is
the integral between t0 and tf.
T0 is just a number say, 3tf.
Again, just the number say 6
of x of t in dt, where x of t
could be any continuous
function, for example.
And a specific class of
functionals we are interested in
is the class of
linear functions,
which are defined by
the fact that they
respect two properties.
The first one is homogeneity.
So the functional of the
scaled version of a function,
so here alpha times x, is
equal to the scaled version
of the function, so
alpha times g of x.
Homogeneity.
OK, thanks.
And the second
one is additivity.
That is the
functional of the sum
of two functions is equal to the
sum of the functionals applied
to the individual functions,
which together lead
to the superposition property.
So, as an example, the
previous functional
is linear because
say that we are--
if you want to do j of alpha
x, which essentially means
the integral between t0 and
tf of alpha x of t in the t,
we can carry out the
alpha from the integral,
which is equivalent to
saying alpha j of x.
Again, nothing deep
here, but just proving
that the example here is indeed
respecting the homogeneity,
for example.
And you can do an equally
simple proof for additivity.
OK.
So next.
So remember that
to define what is
a minimum in the finite
dimensional case,
we use the idea of being
optimal in a neighborhood.
And to define neighborhood,
we essentially
needed to have the concept
of closeness, right?
And to define closeness in
the case of functionals,
we resort to a concept
that is exactly
the one we use also in
finite dimensions, which
is one of norms.
And so specifically the norm
in the case of a function
is a rule of
correspondence that assigns
to each function x, again,
in a specific domain
omega, a real number.
And it is defined as we
do in finite dimensions,
and it satisfies the
following properties.
That is the norm of a function
has to be non-negative.
And it has to be equal--
and the norm is of a
function is equal to 0
if and only if the function
is equal to 0 for all times.
The second property is that
the norm of the scaled function
is equal to the absolute value
of the scaling factor multiplied
by the norm of that function
for all real numbers alpha,
and it has to respect the
triangular inequality.
And in practice to compare
closeness between two functions,
say y and z, what
we do is we let
x be the difference
between the two functions,
and we measure the norm
of that difference.
So it might seem, as
we are doing nothing,
but what we are essentially
doing is just carrying
over all of these results.
We have infinite dimensional--
infinite dimensions to the
infinite dimensional case.
As an example, consider
the continuous functions x.
A possible definition
of the norm
could be the maximum
between t that
goes from t0 to tf of the
absolute value of x of t.
And you can see that this does
indeed satisfy these properties.
For example, the
value of the norm
is, by definition,
always non-negative,
because we're taking the
maximum absolute value.
And the only way the norm is
0 if it is 0 across all times,
because we're indeed
taking the maximum.
So this is for the
first property.
But indeed, I do invite you to
check the other two properties.
But just as an example
of what is a norm for us.
Yeah?
So to set omega, the
functions in that set
have to be related to each
other at all, or is it something
that we choose individually?
No, I mean, omega here is
pretty general definition.
It could be the set of
continuous functions.
Yeah.
So in this case,
they are related,
but I would say just a
domain for our functions.
Yeah?
Could you help bridge the gap?
There's a concept here of
closeness but also [INAUDIBLE].
Why are they connecting
closeness [INAUDIBLE]?
Yeah, this is a good point.
So essentially, the way
we do in finite dimensions
is we use norm kind of loosely
speaking, to measure kind
of distances between vectors.
So usually what works
in infinite dimensions
is literally to revert,
resort to your intuition
in finite dimensions
and trying to map it
to the infinite
dimensional case.
And so here, we're doing
exactly the same thing.
We're using norms
over functions, not
over vectors to measure kind
of distance between functions.
And we can use this distance
to measure, quote unquote,
"closeness".
And this will become more
practical in the next slides,
but this is more or
less what we're doing.
Does it make sense?
Yeah.
OK.
Yeah?
Just to clarify,
the norm is being
taken of the difference
of the two functions,
not on each function.
Yes, correct.
OK.
So we're getting towards
what we actually care about.
There is this defining
extrema for functions.
So now that we have a
measure of closeness,
we can actually do the
exact same thing we're
doing in finite dimensions.
And specifically, a functional
j has a local minimum
at x star of t.
Again, x star of
t is a full signal
just so that we don't get
confused as we would do
in the finite dimensional case.
If there exists an
epsilon greater than 0
such that for all
functions that are
kind of close to the
local minimum, that
is, the distance between
these two functions
is smaller than this epsilon,
the value of the function
is greater or equal
than x of star.
So again, exact
same result that we
have in finite dimensions,
exact same means of getting
to the result, but
we're just extending it
to the infinite
dimensional case.
Yes?
You quote it's
excellent to use signal.
What if the signal be u?
Yes, this is a good point.
So here we are
introducing these ideas
from a high-level standpoint.
For us, we are interested in
optimizing control signals,
which is u.
So in general-- here, we're
using x as a general notation.
But in practice, we will
always be optimizing.
OK.
And maxima, of course,
defined similarly
just by flipping the sign.
Now, to define minimum,
we need to define
something that is similar to
the differential of a function.
And just for-- as a
reminder, remember
that to derive the necessary
optimality conditions
in the finite dimensional
case, what we did
is that we essentially
were looking
at the increment of a function.
And we saw how this
could be approximated
by the value of
the function itself
plus the gradient of
f transpose delta x
plus some higher order
terms, where this is what we
called a differential, right?
So this is exactly
what we did on Monday.
And specifically,
the reason why we
did this is that
we used the fact
that for small enough increments
delta x, the value of a function
is well approximated
by this linear part.
And then what we did is that we
essentially derived conditions
on this linear part
to say something
about the minimum
of the function.
Specifically, we went from this
differential to the condition
that at the minima, the gradient
of f needs to be equal to 0.
So this is what
we did on Monday.
And so intuitively,
what we want to do
is something very similar,
actually, exactly the same,
but again, in the
infinite dimensional case.
And to do this, we
start by introducing
an increment of a
function that is defined
as the difference between
the value of the functional
evaluated at the function
plus a variation of x
minus the value of the function
at the function itself.
And now is where I think, again,
most of the brainpower goes.
So at the high-level, this
is what we want to do.
So we want to follow
exactly the same recipe that
is defined something
similar to a differential
and use this linear part that
well approximates our function
to derive a condition
on this linear part
in the infinite
dimensional case.
To do this, we need to define
a notion of differentiability.
Yes?
The comma is supposed
to be plus straight?
Sorry?
The x of t comma
delta x of t, that's
supposed to be a plus straight?
That's what you
thought or is it not--
No, this is correct.
So we are defining
the increment,
which we express
basically as a function
of-- the original function x
of t and the variation delta.
So that equals what
you were talking
about x plus delta x, right?
No, this increment
would be f of--
So it's a completely
different function than the j
that you were
talking about before?
No, it's this part over here.
So if we bring this
on the other side,
this is the increment
because it's
the difference of the
value of the function,
and this is the difference of
the value of the functionals.
The function else?
Functionals.
Functionals?
Yes.
Does that make sense?
OK.
So here, what we're
essentially doing
is expanding the concept
of differentiability.
And to do this, we first rewrite
the increment in this way.
And specifically, the
increment we rewrite it
as the sum of delta j, which is
a linear part plus some stuff.
And some stuff is the equivalent
of the higher order terms
in the finite dimensional case.
And so here, you
might say, well, sure,
we can always write
something as something
linear plus some stuff.
The point is that to define
what it means for a function
to be differentiable, this
stuff has a specific property.
And specifically
what we're saying
is that if this part g goes
to the limit of smaller
and smaller delta
x goes to 0, we
have something that
goes to 0 times
something that also
goes to 0, which
means that this higher order
terms goes quadratically to 0.
Well, this is a linear
term, linear in delta
x, which means that
goes only linearly to 0,
which means that the increment
of the functional for smaller
delta x is well approximated
by only this linear part.
So again, we're trying to
do the exact same statement
that we were doing in the
finite dimensional case.
And so again, so this is the
notion of differentiability,
meaning that given
that we are rewriting
the increment in this way,
if this condition is true,
then the functional j is said
to be differentiable on x.
And delta j, so
this term over here,
is referred to as the
variation of j at x.
Any questions here?
Yeah?
Is this definition coming
from the Taylor series
or is this just
completely different?
Can you repeat louder?
Is this definition
for the increment
coming from the Taylor series
you're talking about before,
or is this completely different?
It's a great question,
because in a way,
everything that I'm saying
here is s actionable.
Meaning I haven't told you
how to get any of this.
And so we'll see later in the
next few slides how to do this.
So here, what we're only doing
is setting the stage for that
result. Specifically
by setting the stage,
I mean that we are trying to
draw parallels between what
we're doing in the
finite dimensional case,
and here expanding the
notion of differentiability.
Was that a question or no?
Yes.
So for now, we'll just
say it's unrelated.
For now, it's just a result
that is taking a step
into how we actually compute.
Yes?
Sorry.
[INAUDIBLE] by what
the [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
Again, so here, I have
not defined concretely
what any of this is.
Intuitively, you can think
of this part over here
as the equivalent
of the higher order
terms in our Taylor expansion.
Yeah.
OK.
And so this-- once
we have this, we
can formally state the
fundamental theorem
of calculus of variations
or again, kind of i.e.
The necessary and optimality
conditions for our infinite
dimensional problem.
Specifically, the
theorem goes as follows.
So let x of t be a vector
function of t in the class
omega and j of x be a
differentiable function of x.
Again, differentiable meaning
that the increment is well
approximated by the
linear term delta
j that we were seeing before.
Assume that the
functions in omega
are not constrained
by any boundaries.
For now, ignore this sentence.
If x of star is an
extremal, the variation of j
must vanish at x of star.
That is, the necessary
optimality conditions
for our problems is that the
variation of j at a local minima
x star needs to be equal
to 0 for all admissible
delta x is small enough.
So again, here, we won't be
bringing forward the proof
because it's fairly intricate
and in my opinion, not
super insightful.
But in a way, how I
want you to interpret
this result is that
this is exactly
the analog of the gradient
to f transpose delta
x equal to 0 condition
that we saw on Monday.
Now, in the finite
dimensional case,
this was directly leading
towards an actionable thing
we could compute, which
is the gradient of f
equal to 0 condition.
In this case, this is
not yet actionable,
but we'll build towards it.
But intuitively and
at a high-level,
you should map
this result exactly
to the differential
equal to 0 result
in the finite dimensional case.
Yes?
You use a lower case delta j.
In the biggest slide,
[INAUDIBLE] full delta j.
That's the same thing?
We're talking about this
linear part over here.
So the capital delta
is the increment.
So the difference between
the value of the function,
well, plus the variation
minus the original function.
And lower delta here is what we
introduced to be as a variation.
Again, kind of in
your mental model,
I would suggest you see
this as the equivalent
of the differential.
So it's the linear part
that approximates very well
the increment.
And in the finite
dimensional case,
what we did is that once we
had this linear part that
approximates well the increment,
we derived a condition
on this linear part.
Here, we're doing
the exact same thing.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
What is big?
No, I'm not sure
I understand what
the increment and
the linear part is.
Why there's a difference?
So the increment,
we're just defining
as the difference
between the value
of a functional at the
kind of function plus
variation minus the value of
the function at the original--
the functional at the
original function.
So this is just a definition.
Then what we're saying
is that we can--
for variations of the function
delta x that are small enough,
this increment is well
approximated by a linear part.
And then we use this linear
part to basically impose
a condition on this
linear part to derive
our optimality conditions.
Again, I understand how
this can look a bit vague,
because here, it's still
not really actionable yet.
In two slides, it will be.
OK.
But again, so
fundamental theorem
of the calculus of
variations is the analog
of the differential
equal to 0 condition
in the finite
dimensional case, so
the necessary
optimality conditions
in the infinite
dimensional case.
Yes?
The delta x in the delta
j function there is not
the variation of x over time?
Yes, correct.
Actually, this is a good point.
Let me try and give some
intuition to what delta x is.
So say that this is our x of
t, so our function x of t.
We can define-- and
this is like t0.
This is tf.
Delta x could be a function.
There could be
something like this.
So delta x is, in
itself, a function,
which leads to x plus delta
x being something like this.
So this would be
delta x and this would
be x of t plus delta x.
And then j would still be all
of that flipped into, I guess,
the integral that you're
talking about as the example?
We didn't define what
delta j is here yet.
You should just see it as
the linear part, the analog
of the linear part that will
approximate the increment
in the infinite
dimensional case.
Yeah.
OK.
Now, let's make this actionable.
And to do this, let's
start by applying it
to basically an extremely
simplified optimal control
problem, if you wish, the
simplest possible optimal
control problem
we could think of.
Specifically, we
consider the problem
where we want to minimize
this functional, which
is defined as the
integral between t0
and tf of this function g,
which is a function of x,
the derivative of x and n time.
So going point to
the observation
that your colleague
was doing before,
here, you should interpret
this as we want--
as if we are directly
controlling the state
trajectory, for example.
So there is no control,
but we are directly
steering the state
trajectory of our system.
And so some assumptions here is
that g is twice differentiable.
We are assuming that
t0 and tf are fixed.
Again, this is something
we will relax on Wednesday.
But for now, we assume that the
initial time and the final time
are fixed and given.
Same thing for the state at the
initial time and the final time.
X0 and xf are also fixed.
So to basically recap
what we're doing,
so far, we have introduced
the fundamental theorem
of calculus of variations, which
is the optimality conditions
in the infinite
dimensional case, which
we said is not really
actionable and operational yet.
So now, we will make it
operational by starting
to look at a simplified
version of an optimal control
problem, which we
will be building
on Wednesday to until we reach
to the full fledged optimal
control problem.
So to do this, let's apply
the fundamental theorem
of calculus of variation.
And specifically, what we do
here is we write the increment.
So here, we're not really
doing anything particular.
We're just applying the
definition of an increment.
And then we're
substituting our value of j
from our optimal
control problem.
So for us, the increment
will be defined
as the integral between t0
and tf of g of x plus delta
x, x dot plus delta
x dot t in the t
minus the original function g.
We can bring the second
integral inside the first
and we get this
equation over here.
So completely nothing new here.
We're just applying
the definition
of an increment with
respect to our definition
of j in this problem,
which was this one here.
OK, so just a note on notation.
X dot is the
derivative of x of t
and the t and delta x dot is
also the derivative of delta xt.
OK.
So remember what we said for the
fundamental theorem of calculus
of variation is that we took
the expression of the increment.
And then we said
that the increment
would be equal to a linear
part delta j plus some stuff.
Now, here, what we want to do
is from this equation here,
we want to extract the linear
part of this function over here.
Now, in general,
assume a fixed t.
So we are considering only
if you want one element
of this integration.
What is the tool
we would usually
use to derive a kind of the
linear part in this case?
Taylor series.
Yes, exactly.
Correct.
So we will be using Taylor
over and over in this class.
And so this is exactly
what we do here.
So we basically do
the Taylor expansion
of the term inside the
integral, whereby essentially,
the increment becomes the
integral between t0 and tf of g
x, x dot t, plus the derivative
of g with respect to x, which we
refer to as g of x
times the variation in x
plus the derivative of g
with respect to x dot times
the variation in x dot plus
some higher order terms.
So here, we just expanded
the first term, if you wish.
Now, if you look at this, the
first term and the last term
cancel out.
And so what we are
left with is only
with these three
terms over here.
And even by inspection,
what would you say--
out of these three
terms, where are we
sure the linear part
is not coming from?
So I guess you're probably
guessing this higher order terms
element, right?
So even just by
inspection, so we Taylor
expanded our increment, and
we are defining our variation,
that is the linear part that
well approximates our increment,
as this guy over here.
Does that make sense?
Yes?
Does the term in
the parentheses,
does that just represent all
the higher order terms networks
that you're not considering?
Yeah, exactly.
OK.
Now, if we look back at the
fundamental theorem of calculus
of variation, which is
what we want to apply,
we are seeing that the
condition that we had
is basically that the
variation of x delta x
needs to be equal to 0.
Now, what we got here
is the variation.
But this is also a
function of x dot.
So what we're
going to do here is
we're going to massage this
term in order to have everything
as a function of delta x.
Yes?
All right.
Could you just quickly say
how you got capital delta J
to small delta j?
Yeah.
So let's see if
it's somewhere here.
So if you remember, the way
we did it kind of abstractly
is that we defined capital
delta J, so the increment,
as some linear part
plus some stuff.
What we're doing here is we
want to derive the linear part
for this specific case.
So we started by just applying
the definition of increment
to our specific functional,
which led us to this.
Well, actually, it led
us to this guy over here.
Then we wanted to
extract the linear part.
And so we use Taylor
expansion of this first term
to get the linear part,
which led us to this.
Here, the first
and the last term
cancel out and out
of these three terms,
here, we have this
higher order terms,
which is definitely not the
linear part we are looking for.
And so we're just left
with the middle two.
Yeah.
OK.
And now, we said
we want to express
this only as a function of
delta x not delta x dot.
And so we want to
massage this second term.
The way we do this is
through integration by parts.
So remember that--
I think we lost that print.
So remember that we--
integration by parts
essentially entails doing this.
So the integral of udv
is equal to u times
v minus the integral of vdu.
And now, we want
to basically apply
this in the context
of our second term.
So what we have is this one here
from integral from t0 to tf of g
of x dot x dot t
delta x dot in the t.
So we want to apply integration
by parts on this one here,
where we're considering
this as u and this as dv.
And this essentially means,
well, applying the integration
by parts.
So we have g of x dot x, x dot
t delta x dot delta x t0, tf.
So this is the
first part minus--
and I'm not sure if
you're able to see,
but unfortunately, I'm
out of dark markers now.
So the integral between
t0 and tf, right?
Let's try again.
This is great.
So the integral between
t0 and tf of delta
x times the derivative with
respect to time of g x dot x,
x dot t entity,
which essentially
means that now if we take this
and we write the full variation
delta j, what we're getting
is the integral with respect--
between t0 and tf
of g of x, x dot
t minus the derivative
with respect
to time of g x dot x plus
the gx dot t also computed
between t0 and tf.
So here, we use
integration by parts
to massage the second term here.
And then we just rewrote
the full variation delta j.
Now, if we look a little
bit closer at the last term
over here--
actually, I think I
forgot delta x here.
Yes.
So if we look at
this term over here,
we can safely say that
all of this is equal to 0.
Because at t0 and
tf the variations
that are admissible in
our x are actually none.
So we said that x at t0
and x at tf are fixed.
And so the variations that are
admissible are basically none.
Again, visually, what we're
saying is that in our problem
we have fixed x of tf
and x0 at t0 and tf.
And so this means that we
have some fixed boundary
conditions for x.
And so the admissible
delta x here
are none because all of my
points need to pass there.
And so if these are all
zeros, then this entire term
is equal to 0.
And so we're left with
this term over here.
OK.
So for us, we're basically left
that the fundamental theorem
for calculus of
variation results
in this integral over here.
It's your tf of g of x, x
of t minus the derivative
with respect to
time of g of x dot,
x dot times dx dt equal to 0.
So our condition for fundamental
calculus of variation
is that this guy is equal to 0.
And so here, we are just
setting delta j equal to 0.
Yes?
Is the admissible dx
that you're talking about
captured in that dx inside the
bracket, or is it [INAUDIBLE]?
It's in the dx.
This one here.
Is that admissible [INAUDIBLE]?
I mean, in general, we are
looking at the variations
of our functions dx.
And for the problem
that we're looking at,
the admissible variations
of x at the boundary points
are always 0.
OK.
That is [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
And so I just want
to wrap this up,
so I don't steal too
much of your time.
But essentially,
what we're saying
is that for us the fundamental
theorem of calculus of variation
leads to exactly that condition
over there, which is the one I'm
written here on the slide.
Now, does this tell us
anything about the inner--
like the integrand
term over here?
It does.
And it does so through
the last result
that I'm introducing
today, which
is the fundamental lemma of
calculus of variation, which
essentially says that for
any continuous function h,
so any given continuous function
h, the integral between t0
and tf of h of t times
delta x, so if this is true,
so if we have this
result here, this
is only true if
h is 0 everywhere
in the interval t0 tf.
What is the intuition
here is that--
say that this is our h of t
and these are the possible
variations delta x of t given--
if we have any variable function
h of t, say one that is none--
is positive at
some time t, if we
were to pick our variations
adversarially, our delta x of t,
we could always pick
the point that kind of
matches the variation in x in
order to make this positive.
And so the only way in
which this entire integral
is equal to 0 is if h
of t is 0 everywhere.
Does that make sense?
So through this, we essentially
are finished in the sense
that we arrived at
our condition here.
And then we said that
through the lemma,
we know that this essentially
means that this would be our h.
And this is delta x.
All of this integral
is equal to 0
only if this part
here is equal to 0.
And so here, we have
fast tracked Newton.
He basically took 20 years.
We took 45 minutes to
reach to the same result.
And we arrived to the
necessary optimality condition
for the infinite
dimensional case, which
is known as the Euler equation.
I'm out of time, so I
won't stick further,
but I'll recap
this on Wednesday.
Thank you.